this is what i think high value men
should seek as far as qualities in women
femininity awareness following that up
was
maturity maturity in the sense that they
don't have a hissy fit you don't text
her back within
you know her two-hour time frame in her
head and
then she has a complete meltdown over
you class i mean it speaks for self
she doesn't show up with like a big you
know jail tab on her shoulder when you
take her out to a
classy event she's wearing an evening
dress you know what i'm talking about
beauty
obviously you know fertility cues boobs
hips you know bum
a compliment to a man's life and
essentially
i watched a coach red pill video the
other day and he was talking about
what to look for in um women and he
basically boiled it down to a
cheerleader and i have to agree with him
i think that you
want a woman that is your cheerleader